[Alexandrina] Camera traps are used
by the conservation community
to take inventory of wildlife populations
and ultimately measure
the health of biodiversity
in a non-invasive way
using motion-sensor cameras.
These cameras take care
of automatically snapping photos
when movement is detected.
But, the tricky part after is reviewing
each of the millions of photos
and counting each species
as well as bad actors such as poachers.
[camera clicks]
This is where machine
learning is of great help.
And so in this episode, we will share
how to build an image classification
app for camera traps.
So let's dive in.
♪ [music] ♪
Thanks to data,
today, we can understand our natural world
with far greater richness
than ever before
by orders of magnitude.
This now empowers us to build amazing apps
that can help us solve complex social
and environmental challenges.
And so in this series,
let's build an app together.
Meet Tanya from Google,
where her and a team of volunteers
have done an amazing job
at partnering with multiple organizations
to launch a successful image
classifier for camera traps
along with a web app that lets
anyone upload camera trap data
since it's fundamental
in machine learning to use a lot of data.
And so sharing with as many organizations
is essential to research
as many species as possible.
You can check out the website
at WildlifeInsights.org
Wildlife Insights is a project
that's a collaboration
between leading conservation
organizations and Google.
And the bigger picture challenge
that we're facing
is we've lost 68%
of wildlife populations on average
since the 1970s.
Biologists, for a number of years,
about beyond several decades
or even further,
have been using these things
called camera traps.
This is a motion-triggered camera.
The animal walks by,
and the camera takes a series of images.
[camera clicks]
So one of the challenges--
the data is siloed.
Oftentimes, it's housed
in universities or research institutions.
And there isn't an easy way
to share that data.
The second problem is
it's really hard to process.
Like I said, you can be
drowning in all of this data,
millions and millions of images,
and what you really need
is the species of your interest.
So we have been working with
the Google Cloud platform
to upload, to manage, and share, and store
all of this camera trap data,
millions and millions of images
on the Google Cloud.
And then, we've been applying
artificial intelligence models
to understand, make predictions
upon what species is in what image.
This project is quite amazing.
And now, I will walk you through
how to build a simple version.
Let's start with the main ingredients
for the hardware and the software.
From a hardware standpoint,
we need a camera trap
taking photos that's connected
to a microcontroller,
like a Raspberry Pi or Arduino.
This basically serves
as a small Linux computer,
and will have an ML model we install
that labels images of species
and omits blank images.
If it is able to connect to the internet
via a cellular network,
it can send labeled photos automatically.
But in remote areas,
you can carry the microcontroller
to a Wi-Fi-enabled area periodically
to do this transfer.
As a friendly tip,
when managing a large fleet
of microcontrollers,
it's handy to write a script
that uses Cloud IoT core
in order to update all
of your devices simultaneously,
rather than updating each device manually,
especially as the classification
model is updated
with new data from the field.
Next is the software,
which we will be using
cloud computing resources
from Google Cloud.
I think one of the biggest challenges
for this project
is building it upon a robust enough
platform that it can scale,
and also that can handle
the kind of inference
that we'll be doing
when you have biologists
from all over the world
that are uploading their data
and using cloud AI Platform predictions.
For this project, specifically,
the estimated cost per month
is less than $30,
as of the making of this video,
and includes three gigabytes of images.
There are two main workflows
in the solution--
one is a training model,
and the other is classifying images.
And the two products
that perform most of the heavy lifting
is Dataflow and AI Platform.
Let's start with Dataflow,
which is a serverless
data-processing service
that can process
very large amounts of data
needed for machine learning activities.
In this scenario,
we use it to run two jobs.
The first job creates
a database in BigQuery
by uploading two columns
of the metadata
from the camera trap data set
from lila.science.
This is a one-time setup.
Those two columns contain the category
of the label of the species.
The other is the file's name
or the path where the image is located.
It also omits rows that do not contain
relevant information,
which is an essential data
preprocessing step.
The second Dataflow job
makes a list of images
that would be great
for creating a balanced data set.
This is informed by our requirements
for selecting images
that have a minimum and a maximum
amount of species per category,
to ensure that we train a bias-free model
that doesn't include a species
it has too little information about
and is later unable
to classify it correctly.
When this assessment is complete,
Dataflow proceeds
to download the actual images
into Cloud Storage from that
lila.science data set I mentioned.
This enables us to only store and process
the images that are relevant
and not the entire data set.
This keeps computational time
and cost down.
Next, we build a model with AI Platform,
which uses AutoML and the images
we store in Cloud Storage.
Once the model is deployed,
we can classify images.
Let's see what the model thinks
about some of these images.
♪ [music] ♪
This is fantastic!
We have a model working.
Now, the next step is to upload it
to each microcontroller
so that it classifies images locally.
Next time you want to upload
these classified images from the field,
we can save them as JPEG files
directly into Cloud Storage
and their metadata into BigQuery.
Note that you can optionally
collect more metadata information
such as the camera trap's
location, the date, etc.,
and build a simple dashboard
that you can report
aggregated insights of species.
To recap, WildlifeInsights.org
is an amazing project.
And today, we took apart this case study
in order to inspire you
to try to replicate the solution
for your own use case.
So what's next?
Well, I have appended
in this video's description
several helpful links,
including a link to a notebook
that contains all the code
we used for this example,
which means you don't have
to write any of it.
All you have to do is
click Play for each section.
And finally, you can hit Like
or leave us a comment
if you found this content helpful,
and share what other AI for Good
use cases you have in mind.
Thank you so much for watching, friends.
I'll leave you with Tanya's
fun fact about this project.
Cheers.
A fun fact about working on this project
has been putting a camera trap
in my very own backyard.
Yeah, we've caught all sorts of animals.
We've caught mountain lions,
bobcats, foxes, deer,
of course, opossums.
And, yeah, it's really great
to be able to teach my kids
about the wildlife in our backyard.
♪ [music] ♪